die farben
blau
das wasser ist blau
die hose ist blau
der bürostuhl ist blau
die kreditkarte ist blau
der mantel ist blau
weiß
die turnschuhe sind weiß
das t shirt ist weiß
die eier sind weiß
das papier ist weiß
das kissen ist weiß
gelb
die sterne sind gelb
der mais ist gelb
die blume ist gelb
die bananen sind gelb
das feuer ist gelb
braun
der tisch ist braun
der bär ist braun
der kleiderschrank ist braun
die schokolade ist braun
das holz ist braun
orange
der helm ist orange
der kürbis ist orange der ballon ist
orange die karotte ist orange
der orangensaft ist orange
schwarz
der regenschirm ist schwarz
die tasche ist schwarz
die lampe ist schwarz
die fledermaus ist schwarz
die blues sind schwarz
roth
der feuerlöscher ist rot
die tomaten sind rot
das sofa ist rot
das fleisch ist rot
das auto ist rot
grau
die mülltonne ist grau
die straße ist grau
die wolke ist grau der elefant ist grau
der stein ist grau
grün
der baum ist grün
der salat ist grün
der apfel ist grün
die wiese ist grün
die solarenergie ist grün
rosa
das schwein ist rosa
der sessel ist rosa
das kleid ist rosa
der außerirdische ist rosa
der schinken ist rosa
violett
die kommode ist violett
wein ist violett der koffer ist violett
das dreieck ist violett der vorhang ist
violett farbtöne
blau
weiß
hellblau
blau schwarz
dunkelblau